à salut ça va ouais ça va aller vous qui
avez le virus du sport j'espère pas le
coronavirus de temps des eaux et je vais
me un petit pont géant rue mais c'est
terminé si je vous dis grand prix de
chine
annulée et si je vous dis marathon de
paris remporté mais cette année il y à
l'euro et les jo en cas d'annulation les
conséquences économiques peuvent être
désastreuses
j'aime les trucs que dans la fièvre du
sport va t'elle s'incliner face aux
courants navires us on en parle après le
générique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un
nouveau numéro de l'autre match spécial
coronavirus qu'un impact sur l'économie
mais sur l'économie du sport notamment
et sur les conséquences
institutionnelles voire politique et
géopolitique on en parle sur ce plateau
avec nos invités bastien drut bonjour
vous êtes économiste auteur notamment de
le mercato et l'économie du football au
21ème siècle aux éditions bréal à vos
côtés pierre marie descamps journaliste
ancien rédacteur en chef à l'équipe
ancien chef du foot notamment et de
plein d'autres disciplines bonjour
bienvenue
messieurs avant de rentrer tout de suite
dans le vif du sujet je vous propose ce
sondage qu'on a réalisé sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ayrté france le coronavirus
va-t-il tuer le sport oui à 23% non à
77% sur environ 2700 vote votre avis
bastien je sais pas je dirais que tous
les clubs et tout les sports sont pas
affectés de la même façon il ya des
clubs qui notamment de foot qui ont
énormément d'argent qu'ils savent que
ils pourront avoir des recettes est
suffisante sur les années qui arrivent
pour encaisser un éventuel choc sur les
dents les finances quoi en revanche pour
des petits clubs
une perte de billetterie ça peut faire
très mal sa passe et ça peut entraîner
éventuellement la faillite ainsi une
situation difficile se prolonge de façon
à ce que y est tout un tas de matches
dizaine de matches qu'ils soient
annulées par exemple ça peut faire des
recettes de billetterie qui peuvent être
très très affecté et ça peut entraîner
certains clubs normands des difficultés
financières perdant des points ce temps
de toute façon pas là mais j'ai envie de
dire que les différents sports et
différents clubs ne seront pas du tout
affecté de la même façon les gros reste
résisteront beaucoup mieux que les
petits votre avis pierre-marie oui là le
sport est blessé il n'est pas il est pas
tuer encore et je crois qu'il faut
vraiment faire un distinguo entre les
matches à huis clos et les matches
annulés
ça change tout au niveau de l'économie
d'un club pour parler du foot pourquoi
parce que un match à huis clos c'est un
match qui est diffusé or les recettes
principales d'un club c'est la
télévision parce que avec la télévision
on continue à avoir des sponsors on
continue à avoir du merchandising
on continue à faire vivre un club donc
en fait la billetterie dans un club de
foot c'est à peu près à un cinquième de
des recettes c'est pas plus c'est le
cinquième poste d'accord donc tant qu'on
joue à huit clos l'économie des clubs
n'est pas véritablement en danger de
mort notamment pour les gros comme psg
dortmund par exemple cette semaine en
ligue des champions match à huis clos
mais il ya beaucoup de d'événements
sportifs qui sont soit annulés soit
reportée en tous les cas perturber
regarder cette liste évidemment il ya
beaucoup d'autres événements qui sont
impactés mais on vous a concocté
quelques quelques événements le grand
prix de chine qui a été reportée le
mondial de hockey féminin qui a lui été
annulé
avec également les finales de la coupe
du monde de ski prévu en italie à
cortina d'ampezzo il ya des courses
cyclistes également le marathon de paris
le marathon de tokyo ça commence à faire
beaucoup
l'aller les conséquences sur de tels
événements c'est quoi il ya deux façons
d'annuler il ya reporter ou annuler
définitivement par exemple france
irlande de rugby est reportée
probablement en septembre à la rentrée
est une période à laquelle on peut jouer
au rugby et terminer un tournoi
là il y aura pas d'impact majeur en
revanche quand on annule définitivement
et c'est un petit peu l'enjeu autour des
jeunes
et là effectivement ça peut faire des
dégâts considérables comiquement ouais
en fait ya vraiment une gradation il ya
plusieurs solutions possibles il ya le
report pur et simple qui occasionne
éventuellement que des problèmes pour
les personnes qui ont acheté un billet
parce que les personnes ne seront pas
forcément remboursés par ça dépend des
sports évidemment
ensuite j'ai mal de son aile et sont par
exemple là j'ai vu que pour les
destinations ça le serait pas forcément
dans leurs ports de france irlande en
octobre
théoriquement c'est ce que les
organisateurs doit s'il ne produit pas
son spectacle il doit rembourser mais là
c'est ce qui s'était passé pour le match
qui avait été reporté à cause du gel
un peu plus tard il n'y avait pas eu de
remboursement des billets pour les
personnes qui avaient acheté
oui parce que ce sont des circonstances
météo extérieur mais là c'est une
question d'organisation
en fait voilà enfin jeu tout simplement
en fait on ne sait pas est ce que les
assurances peuvent prendre en compte ou
pas donc lorsque j'étais tout à l'heure
c'est le fait que soient les matchs sont
reportés dans le temps et il peut y
avoir qu'un problème éventuel pour les
personnes qui ont acheté un billet soit
il ya les huit clos ensuite
hélas il ne reparte des recettes de
billetterie et ensuite quand les
compétitions sont annuler purement et
simplement ben ça peut occasionner
en plus des pertes de recettes de
billetterie des pertes de droits télé
est donc là les conséquences économiques
peuvent être bien plus importants qu'en
face il y avait une gradation il ya le
report il ya le huis clos est ensuite l
annulation pure et simple
et à chaque fois les conséquences
économiques sont sont différentes et
peuvent être plus ou moins graves quoi
vous avez parlé de deux ouïes de huis
clos là la ministre des sports oksana
maracineanu a dit le huis clos peut
devenir notre doctrine il ya plusieurs
critères par rapport aux annulations au
report il ya les matchs où les
événements sportifs pas que sportive
d'ailleurs de plus de 1000 personnes qui
sont annulés on parle également de cas
par cas suite aux événements qui sont
donc menacés donc des éléments qui sont
menacés maintenant il y en a beaucoup
fait parler des jeux olympiques il ya
également le rô le masters 1000
de rome le mondial de hockey ou encore
d'autres événements quand on perd on
parlait surtout l'italie qui est tout et
tout a été arrêté un idéal de sport
n'existe plus anthony naceria par
exemple le championnat de foot italien
c'est fini jusqu'au 3 avril tous les
sports sont arrêtés en italie jusqu'au 3
avril je crois donc c'est l'italien
depuis le début de cette crise en europe
en tout cas fonctionne un peu comme un
laboratoire pour nous et il faut
observer ce qui se passe là bas
d'ailleurs on a vu que c'était le
premier pays qui interdisait les vols en
provenance de la chine et ce qui était
une énorme erreur
puisqu'on pouvait plus contrôler les
gens qui arrivait de chine
on savait dans quels avions visité l'aï
passé par d'autres villes
et du coup les italiens étaient plus
infectés donc il faut qu'on continue à
regarder au niveau du sport ce qu'ils
font en italie doit être observé c'est
un peu cynique ce que je dis mais à
l'aune de 2,7 laboratoire ce qui se
passe en italie en france c'est-à-dire
sl oui oui mais leurs réactions doivent
être analysés pour peut-être ne pas les
reproduire
oui c'est ça que je veux dire en tout
cas là ils ont décidé d'eux ils ont pris
du retard au départ et là maintenant ils
ont décidé de prendre de l'avancé et de
geler tous et notamment donc l'euro il
va y avoir des matches 1 et qui vont qui
sont prévues notamment à rome l'euro
cette année c'est dans 12 pays
différents dans 12 villes différentes
l'euro 2016 en france les retombées
économiques ont été estimés à 1,218
milliard d'euros selon le cdes de
limoges la commune i à 12 villes 12 pays
j'imagine que les retombées économiques
de ces androïdes par l'économiste
doivent être beaucoup plus importante et
en cas d'annulation
forcément ce sera beaucoup plus dur
alors là on
pas encore là et
2 vous évoquez l'annulation
report de l'euro de melgven finalement
on sait rien du tout ça dépendra
vraiment de comment enfin se continue la
propagation du virus là on voit que
l'italie a beaucoup d'avant sur sur la
france l'allemagne et puis l'espagne
mais les nombres de cas commencent à
augmenter assez rapidement dans ces pays
là si on restait sur sur ses
trajectoires là effectivement on pourra
aller vers une annulation mais ce qu'on
peut voir aussi c'est que par exemple le
nombre de cas de personnes infectées par
le virus au japon et en corée du sud ont
plutôt en train de ralentir
il ya des nouvelles personnes infectées
chaque jour mais c'est plutôt en phase
de ralentissement
donc peut-être que d'ici un mois ou deux
on verra les choses différemment on aura
peut-être un nombre de nouveaux cas qui
aura très fortement ralenti on sera pas
forcément obligé d'annuler l'euro 2020
quoi donc on l'a on fait un peu de la
fiction assez encore assez loin dans le
temps l'heureux 2020 et éventuellement
l'éventuel report et
ou ou annulations mais après c'est vrai
que en termes de 2
de retombées économiques là
effectivement ça a posé un petit peu des
problèmes pour les villes organisatrices
alors je croyais être une seule ville
organise en france mais là il ya douze
villes en europe mais ensuite la la
question si ça sera une question de
finances de l'uefa parce que les
organisations internationales telles ou
telles que les fédérations
internationales telles que la fifa
pendant que l'uefa gagnent beaucoup
d'argent avec l'organisation de l'euro
et si on avait un annulation de leur os
apporterait un vrai coup sûr tout
d'abord aux finances de l'uefa avant il
se trouve que l'uefa a des réserves
d'argent qui sont quand même assez
considérable mais la même question se
posera pour les jo qui sera là la
première instance qui sera affectée par
les jo de tokyo
ça sera le cio parce que le cios et 75%
des recettes qui provient de
l'organisation des jeux olympiques
donc voilà il y aura surtout les
premiers touchés ça sera les fédérations
internationales et ensuite les chaînes
de télévision qui ont payé donc les les
droits de retransmission de ces de ses
comptes pour ces compétitions qui ont
souscrit des assurances mais pourquoi
les chaînes achète les droits des
compétitions c'est pour pouvoir ensuite
gagner de l'argent avec les publicités
qu'elles vont diffuser donc là les
chaînes de télévision sont assurés par
rapport à l'argent qu'elles ont engagées
dans les droits mais elles vont elles ne
vont pas gagner d'argent avec les
publicités parce que justement ces
événements c'est annulé euros par
bastien je moi je vais me fais peu de je
suis pas très inquiet pour les
fédérations internationales comme la
mafia ou même le cio parce que c'est
énorme structure supranationale
depuis quelques éditions maintenant en
l'habitude ont pris l'habitude de faire
supporter le coût de son organisation
par les pays qu'ils aiment résigne et
elle en gros elle s'en mettent plein les
poches
d'accord c'est énorme et voilà on est
dans une économie qui
mais de toute façon ne les impactera pas
autant que les pays qui même les
organisateurs notamment comment est ce
qu'on fait il y avait 28 million de
demandes de billets de l'euro au 14
février dernier selon sur le relief
donc ça veut dire que malgré le
coronavirus il ya quand même une volonté
d'assister à cet événement
c'était avant les terres d'un virus et
la mise en vente des billets est bien
bien antérieur non je crois
qu'aujourd'hui a beaucoup moins de
candidats et et si ça continue parce que
effectivement bastien parler de
d'éventuellement un ralentissement des
laits décontamination on va pour
l'instant plutôt vers un crescendo assez
assez fort qu en europe à moins qu'on
trouve un vaccin efficace dans le mois
qui vient il est pas un vaccin
expérimental on va nettement vers
l'arrêt complet de pratiquement du sport
mondial
vous rendez compte que ou alors il
faudra que qui est des mesures
incroyable ils pourront plus embrasser
après un but nous j'en sais rien mais
non on va le sport va dans le mur
si ça continue le sport allant mur
est-ce que c'est grave
non ce qui est grave c'est qu'il est
mort c'est qu'il ya des gens contaminés
c'est qu'il ya des économies qui sont
susceptibles de s'effondrer le sport
n'est n'est que du sport mais
mais il est il est pas très très bien
engagée on a parlé de l'euro qui est
donc menacée évidemment il y a les jeux
olympiques de tokyo on en parle juste
après la pub à de retour sur le plateau
de l'autre match pour parler des
conséquences du courant un virus pour le
sport sur ce plateau nous inviter n'ont
toujours pas bougé vous êtes toujours
très bien installé un bastien drut et
pierre-marie des commissions on est en
train de parler de la tenue ou non de
l'euro de football il ya pas que l'euro
on a parlé également d'aider gio est ce
que les jeux de tokyo vont avoir lieu
éléments de réponse avec pierre mazars
et conflit mondial oblige les jeux
olympiques de londres en 1944 et ce docu
en 1940 ont été annulés le japon qui
tout cela cause du cours navy russie qui
craint pour la tenue de ces nouveaux
jiho cet été et ce même si le président
du cio thomas bach a exclu la semaine
dernière tout report ou annulation
tourisme hôtellerie commerce autant de
secteurs directement impactés par une
éventuelle annulation tokyo qui investit
12 milliards de dollars a peur pour
cause et je devrai créer deux millions
d'emplois sur l'archipel et gêner les
235 milliards d'euros d'ici 2030 et
forcément aux côtés des assureurs plus
l'échéance approche
on tremble selon les estimations le coût
assuré de la quinzaine sportive
atteindrait plus de 2 milliards de
dollars
la décision finale du comité
international olympique est attendu au
mois de mai au plus tard
[Musique]
les jo de tokyo vont ils être reporté à
nu les messieurs votre avis c'est
intéressant de d'avoir commencer par les
jeux de 1940 qui était prévue à tokyo
parce que ils ont été annulés par la
première et la deuxième guerre mondiale
et là on est un petit peu en tout cas au
niveau du sport dans une situation
comparable il n'y a pas une guerre qui
se prépare mais ça y ressemble au niveau
de l'impact et et moi je serais pas
étonné je suis assez pessimiste je
serais pas étonné que on en arrive à la
même conclusion
quand une fois si on ne trouve pas de
vaccin je ne vois pas comment on peut en
laissant les gens chez eux seulement
rétablir une situation pour c'est dans
quatre mois et demi parce que vous dites
laisser les gens chez eux
c'est ce que demandent également par
exemple florent manaudou le nageur
français la très connue
d'ailleurs un ancien champion olympique
qui a déclaré je pense à ma santé avant
tout un événement comme les jeux c'est
l'occasion rêvée pour le pour que le
virus se propage
il y a dix mille athlètes qui arrive au
même moment deux semaines après il se
redit ce patch dans le monde entier je
ne suis pas sûr qu organiser les jeux
sur la meilleure solution pour éradiquer
le virus vous est de cet avis est
également passé plein de bon sens
après on n'est pas médecin mais
effectivement ça paraît tout à fait
juste cette déclaration de florent
manaudou
alors il ya une info une étude d'une
d'une banque qui s'appelle smbc nikko
securities qui a été publiée par les
médias japonais
récemment qui évalue à 65 milliards
d'euros une annulation des jeux
olympiques
on parle également d'une chute de revenu
national au japon de 24% par rapport à
2019 et 65 milliards d'euros pour donner
un ordre d'idée 4% du pib du japon c'est
la troisième économie mondiale bastien
de plausible je remets en question un
peu cette estimation là en fait ce que
ça vous dire cette étude c'était que
l'impact du coronavirus jeux olympiques
ou non face à refaire ça en ferait
partie
sur l'économie japonaise ça coûterait ça
pourrait écouter 65 milliards et donc
les jeux olympiques l'annulation
éventuelle des jeux olympiques ça serait
qu'une toute petite partie de ça ce que
vous montriez tout à l'heure c'est que
le coût d'organisation des jeux
olympiques c'est aux alentours de 12 13
milliards de dollars voit pas trop
comment quelque chose qui a coûté 12 ou
13 milliards d'organisation coûterait à
l'économie au final 65 milliards donc
c'est aussi le les retombées économiques
parce qu'on sait que les jeux olympiques
on arrive cds de l'image a chiffré entre
5 et 11 milliards des retombées
économiques d'ici 2034 est ce que ce
n'est pas aussi par rapport à ça aux
éventuelles retombées économiques à et
jusqu'en 2034 qu'ils sont obligés de
prendre en compte l'utilisation des
futures installations et c'est pour ça
qu'on arrive à des chiffres qui sont
aussi élevées que ça mais le fait qu'ils
aient de l'hôtellerie des commerces qui
tourne on n'arrive pas du tout aux
chiffres que vous venez
de mentionner c'est vraiment le fait qu'
on met en place des infrastructures qui
seront utilisés sur le long terme qui
fait qu'on arrive à des estimations qui
sont élevés oui c'est très large les
retombées c'est des roots et les
transports c'est énormément de c'est
vrai qu'il ya un impact fort pour ses
très grosse organisation
on n'est plus du tout à ce qu'ont coûté
ce qu'a coûté l'annulation des jeux de
tokyo de 1940 évidemment aujourd'hui le
sport qui verrait deux fois ces jeux
olympiques annuler une fois pourquoi se
veut dire une fois pour cause de virus
ce serait difficile pour l'image de
tokyo
oui et puis on peut il faut penser aussi
au score ce qui représente dans nos
sociétés aujourd'hui c'est vrai que cet
impact là il serait il serait
dommageable pour ce que l'idée qu'on se
fait du vivre ensemble l'idée qu'on se
fait y a pas que l'argent il n'y a pas
eu d impact économique bien sûr c'est
grave mais annulée au dd jeux olympiques
comme ça alors qu'il n'y a pas de guerre
qu'il n'y a pas de conflit qu'il n'y a
pas deux mais pour une raison totalement
exogènes qu'il n'est pas dupe c'est pas
la nature humaine qui a qui a généré le
corps navires us donc oui on serait dans
un dans quelque chose de tout à fait
inédite le sport va au delà de
l'économie le sport on dit souvent c'est
l'opium du peuple
quel impact également pour le spectateur
le fan de foot de jeux olympiques aux
mêmes de nos billets parce que même en
nba on attendait maintenant aux joueurs
de se taper dans la main des fans par
exemple je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'opium
du peuple c'est le coronavirus lui même
donc on parle plus que de ça
savez même les fans de foot et les plus
grands supporters de sport et même des
pratiquants et on l'a vu avec florent
manaudou bas ils s'inquiètent pour leur
santé ils s'inquiètent de ce qui se
passe et c'est quand même très au dessus
de leur immense passion pour le sport
était par exemple est là teddy riner qui
refuse de participer à un tournoi c'est
un jour si je me trompe pas bah c'est
vraiment le fait que la santé passe
avant tout quoi c'est quand même bon
exemple de ça les jeux et je reviens là
dessus est-ce qu'on peut reporter est ce
qu'on peut dire les jeux olympiques
c'est pas du 24 juillet au 9 août mais
ce sera en septembre ça si il y à une
perspective de des souffre le mans de la
propagation du du coronavirus oui et rio
est ce que les japonais peuvent prendre
des mesures d'hygiène on voit la photo
derrière nous est ce que pour maintenir
la tenue des jo au plus grand événement
sportif avant les jo à huis clos ou
alors non les yeux mi-clos je ne crois
pas non plus honnêtement et c'est vrai
que ça permettrait de garder l'argent
des sponsors par exemple des annonceurs
est licite et mes messages je pense que
au niveau des jeux olympiques est un
événement qui a lieu tous les quatre ans
ça me paraît difficile en revanche le
niveau de l'euro on peut imaginer des
matches à huis clos si c'est encore
utile mais c'est dans quatre mois et
c'est possible que ce soit plus du tout
utile sur l'euro on peut aussi déplacé
certains matchs si on était aujourd'hui
au début de l'euro je pense qu on
déplacerait le match à rome
voilà et on les mettrait au stade de
france peut-être pas au stade de france
n'ont pas à faire part au match en
ratant t il ya saint pétersbourg et à
londres ya vu n'est qu'il ya des
endroits où on et voilà ça c'est
faisable assez rapidement mais mais
c'est aujourd'hui dont quatre mois on
voit la coupe de leur au championnat
d'europe des nations dans dans les
écrans je pense également à la coupe aux
grandes oreilles la ligue des champions
on l'a dit psg dortmund à huis clos des
matches en italie qui ne vont pas avoir
lieu comment on fait pas ce que c'est
c'est une compétition maintenant les
matches de poule sont terminés c'est une
compétition à élimination directe faut
que les matchs aient lieu pour pouvoir
déterminer l'adversaire pour que le
public puisse se déplacer dans les
stades suivre les stades pas suivre les
stades les diffuser pour la télé puisse
mettre ses matches à l'antenne ou pas
comment est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on peut
annuler les la ligue des champions c'est
possible ne pas avoir de vainqueur de la
ligue des champions cette année
il reste 21 matches il ne reste que 21
matchs beaucoup c'est pas c'est pas
énorme
s'il ya moyen de les disputer à huis
clos
je pense que l'uefa ira droit vers la
finale à huis clos mais terminant à sa
compétition s'il faut annuler les
matches
ben oui c'est possible qu'ils aient pas
de vainqueur cette année tu faire de
toute façon fin j'ai un gagnent beaucoup
d'argent grâce aux droits télé et je
pense qu'elle va pas se priver d'une
éventuelle annulation va pas se priver
du fait que les matchs puissent être
organisées enfin elle veut pouvoir
compter sur ces les droits télé quoi
parce que c'est vraiment la principale
source de recettes de l'uefa vous voyez
que je viens tu sois aujourd'hui et on
parle de le délocaliser de disputer à
turin en huit lots ils seraient disputés
je crois qu'ils ont ils ont essayé de
faire jouer à malte par exemple voyez
donc l'uefa là-dessus va tout faire pour
amener cette compétition à son terme et
est ce que les résultats sportifs en eux
mêmes ne peuvent pas connaître du coût
des aléas
je pense par exemple aux finales de la
coupe du monde de ski qui devait avoir
lieu à cortina d'ampezzo et à la lutte
pour le gros globe de cristal on parle
d'alexis pinturault pour succéder à luc
alphand au palmarès dernier français
vainqueur de ce gros globe du coup il
manque des courses et manque des points
à aller chercher par ailleurs dans
d'autres sports
est-ce que du coup ça peut pas créer là
il en est injuste vis dans le souhait
ils ont l'habitude parce que le mauvais
temps annule pas mal de courses en ski
dans une rarement une saison de ski de
coupe du monde de ski sans annulation
alors ils essayent de reporter comme ce
sont des épreuves annulées au début de
la saison mais là c'est tous les ans il
ya donc cette injustice là elle sera
beaucoup mieux ressenti je dirais que c
est ce qu a pas une injustice aussi pour
les cyclistes on l'a vu tirreno
adriatico annulé idem pour milan san
remo le paris nice qui a lieu mais il ya
moins de monde à l'arrivée
voilà ce qui a payé à moins de monde
disparaît et le cyclisme a été très
impacté à doha où l'effective m'en
laisser sur les coureurs qui ont été
confinés dans leur hôtel pour une
quarantaine donc vraiment c'est un sport
qu'on doit pouvoir pratiquer par par
périodes de deux d'épidémie ou de
pandémie mais il est lui aussi touché il
ya une chose dont on n'a pas parlé c'est
le fait que l' on parle des compétitions
qui sont les rôles à huis clos mais une
fois qu'on aura des sportifs humain qui
seront contaminés comme ça a pu être le
cas dans le cyclisme
les choses seront encore différente
parce qu'il ya déjà des car il ya une
joueuse de rugby
du coup le match entre la france et
l'école n'a pas pu avoir lieu il ya des
joueurs de la juventus les jeunes 23
du coup cristiano ronaldo un petit peu
crier au scandale donc et là qu'est ce
qu'on fera quand on aura une équipe qui
sera atteinte
entièrement ou 20,6 de transmettre et
c'est au fil du temps enfin ça c'est
encore une autre question quoi c'est
encore plus compliqué on peut le
retrouver au gouvernement donc ça peut
être pire
là je parle à l'économiste par rapport à
toutes ces pertes financières derrière
il ya des assureurs comment vont se
positionner les assurances qui sont tous
en mesure de compter deux de rembourser
est ce que c'est une situation
totalement inédite on ne sait pas
comment faire
de toute façon tout doit être écrit dans
les contrats quoi le fait que soit prise
en charge ou pas et de toute façon je
pense que le sport l'activité économique
du sport en général c'est tellement
petit par rapport à l'économie mondiale
que ça posera aucun problème aux
assureurs de rembourser si les claude
apparaissent bien dans les contrats
d'assurance quoi je pense que ça posera
absolument aucun problème vous les
assureurs ils vont être très impactées
mais seulement sur la base des contrats
organise une brocante annuelle dans le
j'ai demandé vite à changer le meut le
contrat pour mettre le corps d'un virus
ils m'ont dit non monsieur il n'ya pas
d'aléa on sait qu'il existe qu'il est là
est donc impossible de s'assurer donc là
oui c'est moi je ne maîtrise pas tout
haut niveau de l'ehs des assureurs mais
ça va quand même leur coûter vous
maîtrisez au niveau de la presse tout le
monde est ce que la presse est ce que
nous-mêmes on n'en fait pas un petit peu
trop on quand on voit les différentes
une que ce soit en france avec l'équipe
par rapport au cours à navires us ou
même en espagne où il ya des titres
les portes sont fermées à puerta cerrada
la une de as est ce qu'on n'en fait pas
un petit peu trop au final c'est un
iphone est-ce que c'est très conscient
justifier ou est ce que c'est un
affolement médiatique
non on peut pas parler d'affolement
c'est quelque chose qui impacte tout le
monde sans aucune distinction qui touche
londres la grippe saisonnière fait j'ai
fait plus de morts et on n'en parle pas
oui bien sûr nommé depuis un mois que
coronavirus étaient rentrés chez nous il
ya eu plus de morts par la grippe
normale que par la grille du coq
donc bien sûr mais mais tout le monde
est menacé et c'est logique
qu'aujourd'hui dans une société très me
perds médiatisée on soit ce niveau-là
d'informations je vous cache pas non
plus que ça fait vendre
si ça fait vendre c'est pas pour gagner
de l'argent c'est que les gens ont de
l'intérêt pour ça et peut-être qu'au
début il ya eu un petit raz le bol en
disant qu'est-ce qu'on embête avec ce
système aujourd'hui les gens et on le
voit au niveau des achats même pour un
journal comme l'équipe une sur le
coronavirus aujourd'hui ces vendeurs ces
mots de la fin merci messieurs on l'a
compris coup de chaud sur le sport avec
le courant d'un virus bastien drut merci
à d'être avoir répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup pierre marie descamps
vous êtes les bienvenus évidemment sur
ce plateau de l'autre match spécial
qu'on à virus donc émission à retrouver
en podcast ou en replay sur notre site
internet arte france points 1 tv et puis
on se donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre émission est
évidemment à l'autre match sur rt
françois bay
[Musique]
oh